كان من الممكن ان يحدث هذا اللقاء في بكين
لولا حادثه المنطاد التي الغت زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى الصين في اللحظات
الاخيره حادثه يجب الا تتكرر ابدا يقول
انطوني بلينكل لكبير الدبلوماسيين
الصينيين خلال لقائهما الذي كان بعيدا عن
وسائل الاعلام على هامش مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
لاجتماع الذي كان صريحا كما وصف ابلغ
بلينكن نظيره الصيني ان الولايات المتحده
لن تتسامح مع اي انتهاك لسيادتها لكنها لا
تسعى الى نزاع مع الصين او حرب بارده
جديده وستبقي رغم الخلافات على خطوط
التواصل مفتوحه في علاقاتها مع الصين
علاقات تضررت بسبب طريقه تعامل واشنطن مع
حادث المنطاد يؤكد كبير الدبلوماسيين
الصينيين لنظيره الامريكي
شدد على ضروره تسويه الولايات المتحده
للضرر الذي لحق بهذه العلاقات جراء
الاستخدام العشوائي للقوه امر استنكره
بشده كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين قبل
لقائه بنظيره الامريكي امام جمع من القاده
والخبراء الدوليين المجتمعين في مؤتمر
الامن بميونخ معتبرا ان المنطاد كان
لاغراض مدنيه بحثيه
اود ان اقول ان هذا رد فعل سخيف
واساءه استخدام القوه بشكل مطلق
لم يفوت فرصه اللقاء لتحذير نظيره الصيني
من تداعيات وعواقب ستطالب اذا تبين انها
قدمت دعما ماديا الى روسيا في حربها في
اوكرانيا او ساعدتها في الالتفاف على
العقوبات الغربيه كما اعلن عن ذلك في
حسابه على موقع